the reviews collection is a set of small
tables of different heights and
different shapes they create a very
organic composition of landscapes in the
living space
and they evoke a very imaginative
atmosphere with its compositions
we did not set out to design a set of
tables instead day to day we always
doodling sketching when you're working
on projects so we find ourselves doing a
lot of small sketches which are like a
lot of soft organic shapes so when these
shapes overlap one another it forms a
very nice composition
so we thought to relate it back to like
a product a table seems to be quite a
suitable category to design
we begin to laser cut out small models
and putting legs on them and start to
compose them together so once we put
them together it feels like it needs to
be a family of tables
and the challenge was to really look at
all the sketches and all the models
there are hundreds of them and how do we
actually choose tables to form a family
i think the award gathers the best works
so such that it gives a lot of reference
to designers about the the quality and
the bar that the award has set
and i think that'll improve the quality
on design in general in singapore
my advice would be to try everything and
to embrace everything and know that
serendipity sometimes does amazing
things for us as designers
this is rabbit and the tortoise
collection
design of the year
you